[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting rhett's taking me on a
cross-country road trip
i've been waiting to hear
about this road trip i mean well the
moment i heard
you know when i was i was back here in
la you were still in north carolina
you were your your
trips to your trip to mexico was
disintegrating
right before your eyes
and i was i was feeling sorry for you
and then all of a sudden christy's
because she's reading the thread and i'm
not because i'm in full vacation mode
right she's like rhett and locker
they're going to drive back to l.a
you're doing like a cross-country road
trip best idea ever i gotta admit
yeah it's like immediate jealousy like
this sinking inside it's like
yeah well why didn't why didn't they
invite me well you just wait until you
get not that why just wait until you
hear that
if you invited me
that that's not how cross-country chips
work i was on the other coast already
that's why i could have like picked you
up and taken you to my house in the last
like half mile or so
no but like
i would you know the whole week after
christmas that we were all on break i
was like let's do something guys you
know i could always rent a van again and
we can do some a couple of nights
camping
it was there was like torrential it was
raining like crazy rain here it was like
depressing didn't want to go out uh but
it was relaxing
but i you know i wanted to do something
and they wanted to just chill out i
respected that but i was a little
frustrated and then on top of that it's
like man you got this like father-son
thing bonding
seeing places
i've only done one cross-country trip
and it wasn't with my son it was with me
yeah it was
similar route that i took it was
specially about so i want to hear all
about it you've been saving it
yeah tell me on this one you know
even a couple of times
there's been
we've been amongst friends who wanted to
hear about the trip and you've been
there and i had to like say i can't talk
about it because link's here
people are like these guys are so weird
i can't tell you about my trip yeah we
gotta have to wait until now i mean they
understood they laughed because i was
like listen i don't i don't want to have
to act not bored
hearing it a second time on my podcast
that's more important than uh
us talking about it now hopefully
hopefully you're you're the kind of ear
biscuiteer slash mythical beast who
listens to every episode of your biscuit
so you already know
that covid changed my plans to go to
mexico and then i decided to go on a
road trip i'm not gonna tell any more
than that
but i wanted it wait why was it me and
locke like why was it me and my 17 year
old son and not my 13 year old son well
my 13 year old son very likely got
coveted over the over the break and
that's why we we just didn't go to
mexico and so
um locke and i
have been planning on taking a trip
together maybe during we've been trying
to go can we close that loop he's fine
what yeah
experience shepherd he was you know
double vaccinated so he experienced
essentially a cold
um
he was down for a couple of days and
he's he's he's back we never confirmed
that that's what he had because all we
had was those at-home tests and so i i
we we're just assuming that's what he
had but if it's me and i'm not going to
put these thoughts or words in your
mouth and i don't want to throw you
under your family bus here but if it
were me and i was in your situation i
would at that point i would have been
like this presents a unique opportunity
for
me and lincoln to travel across the
country without the other siblings i
mean doing a cross-country road trip as
a family
is a totally different thing than just
doing it with one son we actually it's a
different concept we actually considered
right it was in it was on the table for
us to all go because actually by the
time we left shepard was essentially
recovered
um
but
lock and i specifically have been trying
to plan a trip together you know we were
going to go to japan and then we were
going to go to
i don't know somewhere else and covet
has changed our plans multiple times and
so this is a trip that's been in the
making and he's about you know he's
going to graduate high school this year
so it's important so it's not about
avoiding spending time with your whole
family in one car
but that i had to think that was a
little bit of a fringe benefit well
all it took as jesse and i discussed it
for about 15 seconds as i was like
you know how
our family is so intense that there's a
chance that all four of us in a car
could disintegrate really quickly i mean
there was a chance that me unlocking a
car could disintegrate very quickly but
the chances were were lower now
interestingly i i've talked a little bit
about lock and his tendency to be you
know he's an enneagram eight he's a
challenger and so one of the things that
i have found to be consistently true is
when you have an idea even if it's a
great idea like a cross-country road
trip his initial reaction to it will be
one of um
doubt and skepticism right and so almost
instinctive oh yeah and i knew that was
gonna happen
and
lo and behold when i pitched the idea of
hey man day after christmas let's just
drive back to los angeles
it wasn't an immediate like this is a
great idea it was like
[Music]
how many hours is that going to be in
the car like th these were the questions
right i don't want to it's a legit
question i i don't want to spend too
much time on this point because
obviously we ended up going but the way
that i i kind of went into a dad pitch
and jesse was involved and we did a
little bit of good cop actually good cop
good cop um but i just said listen
it's very difficult for the future lock
to
understand what is being proposed right
now and that is
cross-country trips of any kind well
future lock is not here he's in the
future right
you know what i mean
it is very difficult for your future
self to
look you can't look back and appreciate
what you are about to experience in a
cross-country trip and also as someone
who has lived an adult life for some
time
i know how hard it is to come by a
cross-country trip these are these
aren't things that just present
themselves but i've never met someone
who was like i regret my cross-country
trip i really regret it now i'm sure
there are people who do but most people
are like when i think about some of the
formative experiences when i think about
some of the things that i remember
in my life oh that cross-country trip
like these are formative
experiences and memories and i was like
you're not going to regret going on this
you will regret saying no potential so
so you sold the experience and your
future self will thank you yeah i've had
to do that a number of times i mean did
you say and you know what
we're going to be announcing our
location and meeting with fans of mine
at rest stops
off the interstate nope all across
america
all i did was severely slow down our
progress as we stopped at multiple rest
stops uh oh during the first rest stop
stop i did say you know
there was a point in time about a decade
ago where link and i did a cross-country
trip and stopped and announced our
to our fans that we were stopping at
various rest stops and instead of
thinking it was weird he was like
that's cool man it was cool it was if
you're interested in that you can just
google mythical road trip the videos are
spread across
two different channels
of course this is pre gmm so across the
gmm channel and the main channel
uh
so you do some work to piece it together
for yourself maybe there's a playlist um
i am going to be
yeah i took a lot of video took a lot of
pictures including we took a couple of
those disposable film cameras that
apparently take a week to develop that's
why they're not developed here oh like a
wedding yeah but between all of that uh
visual media if you're if you want to uh
if you're just listening to the podcast
just know that the youtube version of
this is going to have a lot of that
visual stuff i'll show you some if if
it's needed for context as we go i'll
watch the video or you can just watch
later
but i don't want to spend a lot of time
on my phone so
how much planning did you have i mean
was this i mean so he would you sold him
let's where did yeah where were you left
off so it was like he was like i'll do
it dad you're gonna leave on the 26th
did he have any stipulations was he like
well one of the things that he had to do
is he had two he has two things to do
he's taking a uh like a german course
that's outside of his school
uh because before he transferred high
schools a long time ago he was he was in
the german curriculum and so he needs to
finish to like get to like i think he's
doing it he's in germany
car manufacturing what was it uh it was
just the language of germany oh just the
line uh and so he had so he needed to do
that because it's he's got to finish it
by like mid-january so he needed to
spend some time doing homework
uh he's also currently applying to more
colleges than the ones he's already
applied to so we needed to do some like
essays and stuff like that and i was
like listen we've got this giant suv
that's way too big for us it's super
comfortable this is like a it's like a
mobile classroom it's like one of those
families that has a school bus that just
takes your kids around doing homework
all the time so there'll be plenty of
opportunity for homework because i'm
gonna drive it's a rental car you're not
allowed to drive this thing so you're
gonna be able to do a lot of homework he
was like yeah okay okay yeah all right
um
but this is like the 23rd or so 22nd
23rd when we made the call to cancel the
mexico trip
and decided to do this so in terms of
preparation actually i let jenna know
that i was doing this cross-country road
trip and she was like well you should
check out the website roadtrippers.com
um and i did and that was actually thank
you for that jenna that was very helpful
because what you end up doing is you
basically
go on there and you set your destination
your you know your origin and your
destination and then it has it creates a
corridor around the the route like a 30
mile wide corridor which in my case was
on 40 because i was going to take 40
because i didn't want to just go
i wanted to get home but i wanted to be
able to experience some stuff as well
but i didn't want to do one of these
things where you're like going up north
also
winter weather was happening and i'll
talk a little bit more about that and we
had actually had to divert our route
because of that but i wanted to stay
40 or south i didn't want to go too far
to the north
and this i mean it's a cool uh site
where you just you see things organized
by category and you click on them and
you can just add them to your trip and
of course you can then it's like it
automatically sends that navigation to
your navigation app on your phone so
you've got the mobile app you've got the
computer
uh and with the information and like
people's reviews of these different
places and you have to buy a
subscription for this they here's how
they get you
so i'm sitting there planning my trip
and i'm about like four or five
destinations
in or four or five stops in and then it
was like to add a seventh destination or
for unlimited destination adding please
sign up for our
subscription service and i was like boy
i've spent an hour so far doing this and
so there was a genius system
and so i ended up paying like the yearly
fee
to basically subscribe to the thing
um
but i don't even know the chances of
using it again
they know are very low it wasn't for you
yeah well i'm going to not pay again
or i'll probably forget and pay again
exactly
this is how they make their money and i
have no regrets right uh and so all we
knew is that we wanted to get to la by
like
new year's eve so
if you go from the 26th to new year's
eve that's a total of six days
me and you went pretty aggressively when
we went with our u-haul and i think we
did five days or so
uh i think
it was either four or five it was not
six i'm 100 sure how did we do that well
it's not that hard as you're about to
find out even when you take multiple
stops more stops than than wheat than me
and you did the only stock we took for
ourselves was the grand canyon all the
other ones were just to meet mythical
beasts yeah so the grand canyon was on
the itinerary
didn't happen oh the reasons i'll
explain in a second okay so i i'll get
into talking about the first stop in
just one moment first we want to let you
know about uh a rubik's cube the rubik's
we invented this thing called the
rubik's cube
and we thought it would be cool to put
our face on it no this is we actually
partnered with the official rubik's cube
company and we created
a
rhett link mythical themed rubik's cube
it's got our faces making various faces
faces
uh on each
face
and it is solvable
uh but just not by us right now that's
why
it's not currently solved
it was solved but it looks great when it
when it came in the in the mail when you
buy one available for a limited time
it will come to you solved and then it's
up to you to watch a youtube video and
figure out i gotta take this one home
lincoln knows how to solve a rubik's
cube so you know what it's like it's a
good life skill if somebody here in the
office doesn't so it might be the only
time it comes in really handy and
putting our and you mix it up and it
makes funny-looking faces that are a
combination of
parts of my face in your face which is
something i didn't anticipate
go to mythical.com
get yourself the official
rubik's cube collab with mythical okay
so based on the amount of hours that we
needed to be on the road i had an
estimation of like we need to kind of
hit like an eight hours of driving per
day or so to kind of keep the pace up
now
that's a lot
i don't think you i think for a
leisurely place you don't want to go
much more than five
if you're me i disagree and that's what
i thought going in
your vehicle
makes
all the difference in the world you know
when i took my my my solo trip and i
took my fj like my 2007 fj that's got
big tires on it makes all kinds of noise
and it's just not a great car for going
long distances it's a great car for
getting over rocks and stuff yeah i was
absolutely mesmerized at the the size of
the country and all i did was go into
like nevada and then come back down to
cal and then come back to california
i was in a
this is not an ad for a ford expedition
but i was in like a new ford expedition
and
something about how smooth
the ride was
made
both lock and i come to the conclusion
that the united states isn't that big
like that that's actually how we were we
would drive and be like sitting for
eight hours it wasn't that bad i mean
and i'll talk to you about some of the
ways that we have a still time driving
yeah it's a standing desk situation the
top goes up and you just sort of like
stay that would be awesome
uh i mean rvs and buses should printer
bands should have that but then it's
it's really hard to do about the pedals
control the gas and brake pedal while
standing right that's probably why
that's illegal but no it didn't seem
like i was thinking like ups i was
preparing
i told lock i was like dude
mom and shepherd get back on the second
you go back to school on the third
as long as we're back before the second
i i set really really low expectations
for how much we needed to move and he
was on board with that but we did have a
place that we wanted to get on night two
which
i'll explain in a second so first you go
first we wanted to go and stop and stay
the night in nashville which is about
seven and a half eight hours from uh
fuquay of arena which is our point of
origin which would you have thought
thought that all the way to nashville
tennessee just like seven or eight hours
it's not it's just pretty close i would
have said yes that's pretty far
okay
um
yeah i don't need to be asked i wasn't
in an expedition i don't need to be
asking you like how long things feel in
mileage and time though because
things kind of break down pretty quickly
all i knew is that i wanted to stop
we wanted to get out of on the road very
early so
the night before locke wasn't staying
with us he was staying uh with his
cousins and i was staying with jesse's
parents and i was like bro you just
bring your stuff over get your clothes
washed i'm doing telling the 17 year old
the things that 17 year olds need to
know before they leave you know just i
was like be ready
he basically wasn't ready until very
late that night he went and hung out
with his cousins but he was ready we
woke up
uh well no that right before sorry right
before we went to bed i forgive you i'm
going i'm asleep it's 11 30. i'm gonna
get up at like 6 30 and we're going to
get on the road at 7 00 am that's the
plan
he knocks on the door wakes me up he's
like dad i broke my crown so lock has a
crown on his front one of his front
teeth right here on the whatever that
middle tooth the incisor okay and
it had cracked right across the front
now thankfully my father-in-law was a
dentist and we were staying at his home
and he was still up
and then so he was like okay i can fix
it tomorrow
uh
and then he's like oh no tomorrow's
sunday i won't have any assistance and
then he's like let me look at it he
looks at it he's like oh you're fine
until you go to california at that point
i thought it was going to be delayed it
wasn't it was like break off the the
facing of it had cracked off
but it wasn't like exposing the tooth
the root or anything like that or the
nerve
so right off the bat i was a little a
little intrigued i was a little tense
like
but we did end up leaving at 7 00 a.m
first stop was going to be in asheville
because if you're going to nashville you
should stop at a town that rhymes with
it before you get there that's a rule of
thumb that the app told you that yeah uh
and i knew
definitively that i wanted to eat at
biscuit head
for lunch okay first stop asheville
biscuit head
lattes
filthy animal
oh okay this is gonna be good biscuit
heads
is a restaurant in asheville there's
actually three locations i didn't know
that uh this is a place that
you know specializes in biscuits oh my
mouth is watering and those big tall
stacked fluffy
buttermilk biscuits with like
bacon egg and cheese i'm gonna tell you
exactly what we ordered now
the so i was
in large part building the trip around
food
you know that's what i think about most
of the time so i was like we're not
going to have a bad meal on this trip
we did which i'll get to in a second but
the plan was to not have a bad meal on
this trip
it was about the destinations and the
sightseeing but it was also about the
food and we wanted to get started on the
right foot now i didn't know this but
the whole biscuit head of it all
apparently there's something called like
a cat head
biscuit which is a southern vernacular
for
essentially biscuits and gravy like when
you take a biscuit and you put stuff
over the top of it i don't know they
said something like that on the menu i
was like oh i didn't know this i've been
to this place several times but we got
the filthy animal
which is a buttermilk biscuit with fried
chicken on top of it pimento cheese oh
god bacon
scrambled eggs
all smothered in gravy
if you go there smell it and gravy this
is their specialty you gotta eat it with
a fork you definitely gotta eat it with
a fork
uh
this is what i recommend that you get to
fill the animal everything's good though
so
lux keep the change already having a
great time you know we're spending a lot
of time listening to music
um i'll talk about a little bit about
some artists that he i helped him
discover along the way but we're having
a good time and we were just very sort
of like man we got here real fast it
feels like we just got to asheville
real fast we eat but like we want to get
to nashville because i'm like
not only are we going to nashville to
get some hot chicken of course but we
all want to show him downtown nashville
and
show him you know the honky tonks and
all all this stuff so
on to nashville which we end up arriving
in nashville at like
3 30 p.m
like we got there with plenty of time to
spare okay official stock number two
nashville
don't look at yourself man look at the
camera man now
you probably already know this if you
live outside of some major metropolitan
areas like los angeles
but uh covet does not exist
uh in nashville tennessee
uh
apparently has not made it there which
is news to me i thought i think they
completely eradicated it mentally yeah
wait
exactly it turns out that most of the
country has eradicated coveted mentally
yeah uh it does not exist in any of the
states after nashville until i got to
like phoenix
and again as i kind of outlined a couple
of podcasts ago is someone who's double
vaxxed and boosted from we were both
double vaxxed and boosted i was kind of
like listen i kind of got to just go
along with the flow of america here on
this trip or else i'm gonna drive myself
crazy so that's essentially what we did
um
but we were gonna do the main thing i
wanted to do in nashville was to get hot
chicken so we took a little tour of
downtown
um stepped inside a a honky tonk where
the you know i like to i go into the
places where
first of all
it's a little bit mind blowing for even
if you've never been there for like lock
it was really mind blowing to let's just
walk up and down this street and
literally every single restaurant has
got a person a band playing music right
yeah including taco bell uh seriously a
lot of it is very bad
i would say
the majority of the music that i heard
coming out of those places is pretty bad
i'm not a huge fan of modern country it
gets better the later you stay but if
but you go to a place where there's guys
that there's some somebody's got gray
hair you're like that's a good sign
there's a dude who looks who's playing a
pedal steal who looks like this may be
his last time ever playing the pedal
still you may die while on stage yeah
you know you're and also there's hardly
anybody in there watching except some
other old people i saw that place and i
was like this is where we need to go we
go inside
over the course of like five songs they
played three merle haggard songs do you
remember which one it was i can't
remember the place that was our favorite
from when we played at the ryman i do i
don't remember the name of the place it
was a woman's name uh it but it was it
was towards the river and pretty close
to like the glen campbell museum and a
little road to go off to get to the
johnny cash museum which i didn't go
into we just kind of took a picture for
shepard and they would like lock in
there
underage
dude there's no rules man okay
they they are in fact
the waitress offered him a beer i mean
he doesn't he doesn't look 17. he look
no and i was like ah let's not do that
uh so
we did that but then it was all about
the hot chicken now yeah i'm curious
where did you go so my experience the
first time i ever had
authentic nashville hot chicken which a
lot of people like you talk about spicy
chicken hopefully if you've watched good
mythical morning you know that hot
chicken is not spicy chicken it is its
own category it's not like the spicy
chicken sandwich you get at mcdonald's
okay this is a very specific recipe and
it's very good and it's one of my
favorite things the breading is very red
yeah it's got it has a lot of spice
mixed into the breading and then it's
got it's got like a coating of like dry
but also a little bit wet you got to
just have it so the best i've ever had
is hattie bees in nashville
but
i had even heard that nash
hattie bees was not the originator of
hot chicken
we were told when we went there that
bolton's chicken and fish hot chicken
and fish was the originator and we went
there and it was very very good very
down home but it turns out that that's
also not true
bolton's is not the first person to do
it the first place to do it is princess
hot chicken i never even heard a
princess hot chicken but i'm telling i
told you about princess hot chicken i
thought you told me about bolton's no no
no when we went to when i took the kids
to the wedding in nashville last year we
went to prince's did you go to the one
in assembly hall
or did you go to the original location
it was on a i think the original
location after the fire okay not the
original original it was in a strip mall
i had we waited way too long for it well
i blocked that out of my mind and i'm
probably about to tell you something
that you already know but just let me
tell you so
assembly hall is like a sort of like a
food court on steroids a mall near
downtown right across the street from
the the from the ryman
yeah that's where you went there's a
princes there yeah yeah yeah yeah
there's a hattie bees there
there wasn't when i went okay okay all
right so i went to the hattie b's there
which it must be right at this in the
same place
princess is upstairs in the food court
area honey bees is down in the outdoor
mall so you went for princess
okay lock and i got into this discussion
and i was like listen i'm gonna tell you
right now i've never had better hot
chicken than heddie bees
but i've also never had princess and
everyone is saying that princess is the
original place and then we go online and
we're looking at
all these lists of the places that you
should have hot chicken and like list
after list is like go to princess for
the original it's everyone is just
trying to imitate that it's true so i
was like what okay
i mean it's not going to be a
disappointing experience i mean it may
not be as good as hattie b's you know
side by side comparison or whatever
but the thing that locks it was like dad
but there's a lot of people in line at
hattie b's and there's not a lot of
people online at princess and i was like
well that's just because it's like a
it's upstairs in this place and
you know hattie b's is a better location
and but i was also like
okay you just tell me which one you want
to do and he was like i think we should
go to the place that has more people at
it and i was like but what about the
original i i i take full responsibility
for this because i talked him into going
to prince's dad said do you want to get
the best or do you get the original i
said let's get the best he's that we
gotta get there original we got it it's
pretty shitty no it wasn't bad at all it
wasn't bad
but it was bad it was bad i can't
believe i did the same thing but you
ended up getting
you got to rectify it yeah i went to
hattie b's the next day well i wasn't
able to do that because i had to leave
let me just tell you right now
and and once i got up there and we put
our order in and by the way
we also got t-shirts that said princess
hot chicken because i'm looking for
t-shirts and i got a hat at biscuit head
we're getting memorabilia all over the
place
road trip is all about that's a good
idea so i um
we order
a couple of like medium
hot chicken sandwiches which typically
medium is like super hot if you have any
experience with hot chicken you never
get the the hot's like hotter than
anyone can handle and there's two levels
above that and it's just kind of like
comical to even think about right
typically yeah so i noticed there's
there's a lot of people in line
uh there's a lot of people waiting not a
lot of people in line but a lot of
people waiting and then at that point is
when i go to the specific yelp reviews
not for princess but for this prince's
location which is like a not the
original location it's like the mall
location yeah it's the tourist trap
downtown and i begin to get a sinking
feeling because people are like this
place is so poorly managed it's not
going to be representative of hot
chicken it's just a piece of chicken
with some sauce kind of dolloped on it
and then i'm just thinking these people
ah there's no way it's that bad there's
no there's no way a place that has this
reputation is letting this happen i mean
it's not going to be bad i mean the
worst it's just going to be a good fried
chicken sandwich
it was the most disappointing culinary
experience i've ever had in my entire
life man i wish you would have gone just
downstairs to the hattie bees right
afterwards well the line they had
remember what i told you because it was
so good i wasn't sure that you said
princess it's touristy
i mean everything in that area is is for
tourists but like howdy bees they've
they've made
they've optimized the tourist experience
with some of the things that they offer
well but it's also it's just good i mean
they feel good it's good and it's
consistent and i should and so lesson
learned for me first of all i had to
apologize profusely a lot we ended up
getting like some ginny's ice cream
after
i i almost was like let's just go and
get right back in line and just get
hatty b's but that line was probably an
hour long and we kind of retired and
wanted to go to bed
but i i can't speak for the original
princess location but if the prince's
enterprise is allowing any location to
be as horrible as the one in assembly
hall
then i'm i'm never going i will never go
you cannot you lost your opportunity to
gain me as a fan hattie bees is amazing
and they have a good experience bolton's
is really good but howdy bees is the
standard you shouldn't go to the place
that
that created it you should go to the
place that perfected it and they have
perfected it for at least for tourists i
totally agree by the way there's a
hip-hop themed pizza restaurant right
across the way from it in that same
thoroughfare and i recommend that place
too well if i had to spend multiple days
next time i come through i know what i'm
cinnamon rolls um we stayed at the
graduate hotel on music row i don't know
if you know about this place but it's
basically a country music themed hotel
that has some awesome decor and like
pictures of dolly parton in the in the
lobby and
your key your cards for getting in and
out of your room are like student ids i
had like waylon jennings student id and
johnny cash's student id is like what
you have as your your key to open your
door student id this made up it's not
real i don't think they ever had yeah
emmy lou harris a a portrait of her was
over my my bed wow um i can't remember
who was overlocked but i've got pictures
you're probably seeing them at this
point but that was a fun experience also
shout out to the front desk their
mythical beast at the graduate at least
those that i interacted with that night
um but we got up the next morning you
get a chocolate on your pillow a night
chocolate they don't do that it's not a
country for you
uh so next day we're up and the goal is
to get to
chester arkansas
never heard of it no reason to have
heard of it until today
hopefully i'm going to give you a reason
to hear about it but we were going to go
through melfos so we knew we were going
to stop in memphis and again i'm
thinking about two things i'm thinking
about and ribs i'm thinking about
stopping at central barbecue which has
the best ribs we've ever had if you
remember the the i'm crying our memphis
trip where we decided on what the best
ribs were and it was clearly central
barbecue wanted to stop there but the
downtown location is directly across the
street from the civil rights museum
which is at the lorraine hotel which is
where mlk was shot and killed
um and i've never been in there and i
was like this will be a cool thing for
father and son to do we get to
have this incredible meal and then we
get some essentially some sobering us
history in the middle of our trip um
but turns out that the central barbecue
location was closed
at that for some reason it was closed
and i was like well i've got my heart
set on this so i had to drive 15 minutes
to the original central barbecue
location which is on central avenue i
didn't know about this uh so i've now
i've seen the other one it's a lot like
the second one so you so you were at the
mlk museum
but since central barbecue was closed
you for
you didn't go in the museum well we were
it was lunch time we were super hungry
we had to get the central bar we wanted
to spend a couple of hours at the museum
i wasn't about to go in there uh we were
also yeah we weren't eating breakfast we
were like getting a coffee when we woke
up and it was like we're gonna we then
we vanished i i
i've been doing like an intermittent
fasting thing and lock is amenable to
pretty much anything so that's what we
decided to do there's also you can kind
of get on the road and just go so
go to the original central barbecue
location
uh
i gotta say i love central barbecue but
for me it really is the thing that
shines is the ribs and everything else
is kind of just like good barbecue but
not great barbecue i don't remember if
that was your experience if you remember
we were we were already so full when we
got the spread from
barbecue when we went there why we were
on a rib mission so did the ribs hold
true the ribs are so good
the ribs but i got ribs
pulled pork and i meant i ordered
chicken i thought i was ordering the
smoked chicken but they gave me the
shredded chicken like the pulled chicken
oh it's a little dry um and again i
think i said that the rendezvous beans
were better i got beans and they're not
bad but it's really just get the ribs if
you're a rib person get the ribs but
going back to the
civil rights museum which again so you
did go back to the civil rights museum
oh yeah i wasn't that's what i was
asking you seemed like you were just
like i have to make a choice and it's
gonna be for them no no no no i'm saying
that
okay we wanted to
i mean it's still in the same town i'm
driving across the country 15 minutes is
it going to be that you're on an
expedition so we go to the museum
everything seems so quick and
i mean
listen i mean you can imagine
the sort of intensity of the experience
of the civil rights museum but
um
there's i can't really say anything to
communicate that i just gonna tell you
if you're in memphis you should go to it
right and i think that the story of the
hotel and how
after he was killed there on the balcony
um
the story of the thing falling into
disrepair and then like local leaders
coming together and saying we want to
save this hotel
and then they literally built the museum
around it and inside of it but kept the
two rooms right there the one that he
stayed in and the one that i think they
had a meeting in or one that he was shot
in front of
they kept them intact and then they've
added some like things of like this is
what would have been on the table and
here's like the ashtray with cigarettes
that they have been smoking and stuff um
it's just a really well done museum that
has so much information actually felt
bad because
it's there's so much information to read
and to digest and there's so many cool
things to watch and experience as you go
through
but when you're on a road trip and
you're kind of like we got to get we
have to get to to chester for reasons
i'll get to in a second so we actually
only did like two-thirds of the museum
there's a whole other side which kind of
goes underground and i think goes up to
the place where the shot was fired or it
gets close to it i'm not i didn't go in
so i'm not sure i'm speculating but
definitely recommend
that and it was it was very just seeing
the spot
seeing this like hearing the story and
then like standing up there right next
to where he was shot is just like a
it's a sobering experience for anyone
okay um but then on to chester arkansas
so that was what was kind of driving us
to get to
uh to to get to nashville into memphis
then the chester to spend the night
so we talked a lot about lance and lacey
of beard and lady
some really good friends of mine and and
of ours
uh who beard and lady makes all the you
know the mythical grooming products the
and also helped us kind of come up with
the idea originally for beard oil and
lip balm and all that stuff
well lacey is from
this area of arkansas which is right off
of
40 as you're coming through because most
of our trip was on 40. i mean they're
like literally like 15 minutes from 40.
so as soon as i'm mapping through i'm
like hold on this goes right through
arkansas and i was like this is like
right next to where they've got this
hotel
so they have
bought this historic like 100 year old
hotel in chester which is a very teeny
tiny town
uh and they have a museum around it no
it's not it's not like the museum
they have restored it and it's called
the beard and lady inn and it has three
components number one it's a hotel with
11 rooms so it's kind of like a boutique
hotel okay i'll tell you about the rooms
in a second it also has a restaurant
that serves like local arkansas
uh wild game and stuff by the time this
goes out and you're listening to this it
will be
basically they're opening up the
restaurant like as we speak all this
information is at beardenladyin.com but
there's also a mercantile so like a
store where they sell
mythical products but also a bunch of
other stuff from like local vendors if
you're like a
northwest arkansas person and you've got
something cool to sell like there
there's so much room in this incredible
facility they've set up that you can you
know you can they're doing all kinds of
stuff there
i mean i highly recommend it if you're
coming through because it's just like
it's definitely the coolest place that
we stayed even cooler than graduate just
because of the history of this place and
also it's haunted is it yeah so it has a
reputation in fact as they were you know
they bought this thing a couple years
ago and then they slowly restored it and
they said that like locals would come by
and be like
you seen the ghost yet you know like
basically this place is notorious for
being haunted so i think it'll also be a
destination for like paranormal seeking
people doesn't that play into the theme
i think yeah so this is remember
the theme of the rooms is there it's
either fear of something or it's just a
a general theme about a life experience
and so
but it's kind of funny in that like i
stayed in the fear of commitment room
right and so lacey's family history goes
way way back in that area and her
grandparents were like incredible
collectors or archivers of their family
history and pictures and stuff and so
they've got these pictures
in that room that i stayed in there's
all these pictures of her grandparents
and relatives and their like wedding
portraits and pictures of them together
throughout the years all this old like
like tin type
old-school black and white photography
and everything basically tells the story
of commitment yeah so it's like okay if
you've got fears
let's see all these people around you
that are committed to one another
interestingly one of the rooms uh which
i think is fear it might be fear of
death
uh
you can go on the website and see all
the rooms but her grandparents
her great grandparents
are the only people
known on record at least on record at
the time to request
a dual coffin what they died within
hours of each other
and a dual coffin was made for them and
there's pictures of them in the coffin
on in the room what
it's incredible so is it first okay
first of all
did was they how did they die so so
close so closely because i guess the
first thing i thought was okay one of
them dies you bury them then you got to
dig it up and throw the other person in
there yeah i think it was they were
counting on dying at the same time i
think that the circumstances led to
she died or he one of them died first
and the other one knew that they were
about to die i don't think i can't
remember the story of the same disease
or whatever it was in the same coffin it
was i think it was like a last minute
request like that and they totally did
it it was was it a wider coffin yeah
like a square it's like a square coffin
what yeah there's a picture there's
pictures of them in it dead bodies in it
yeah we'll see but you don't have to
stay in that room it's all about your
level of comfort and there's one room
that is known as the haunted room i
didn't stay in but first of all the
whole whole place is potentially haunted
right
but there's one room that is right above
the place where a guy
once like froze to death in like this
little i think this like saloon that was
attached to it
again all these stories in in more
detail are on the website
but i didn't stay in that room but we
walked we were they're just opening and
so there was one other couple that was
staying there that night and then it was
me and locke and we stayed in adjoining
rooms
uh you know uh lance and lacy's history
of like traveling multiple times to the
middle east over their 20s and 30s and
so there's there then they've got all
these like artifacts and like a camel
saddle and all this stuff
that was connected to my room so the
middle east room which is not a fear of
anything it's just a middle east theme
room and then i was in the fear of
commitment room and then there's a
bathroom attached to that and so that so
we kind of had adjoining rooms okay um
but it's really hard for me to convey
how cool and unusual of a space it is
and the thing that they're trying to do
because it's on
the
railroad
and they're currently like basically
lobbying to get it added as a stop so
you can be in one of the major
city centers that's close by north and
south take a train you can take a train
and and it'll let you off
and they've also bought
a church like this hundred-year-old
church in a nearby place
the whole idea is that people and i
think this is already they've had a
couple of wedding parties because it's a
really cool thing to run out of the
whole hotel
and
you know have an event
and
they bought this church and the idea is
that in the future people will get
married at this venue
and then die in the hotel and then go to
the hotel uh and again if you're into
paranormal stuff it's great if you're
not there's plenty of options and plenty
of rooms to stay in that are not but it
was one of the coolest
coolest stops that that we made and then
they kind of took us on a tour of you
know the family land and some other
stuff the next morning and
uh we got to see some some of northwest
arkansas which is a which is a special
place special place special place huh
hilly yeah actually it's it's pretty
yeah pretty mountainous i would say i
would call it it feels like you're in
the north carolina mountains and i mean
essentially i think i don't i think it's
a different mountain range right because
it's like ozarks okay uh but it has that
feel of like very wooded
mountains that you just feel like you
get lost in lots of lakes and stuff lots
of streams and rivers that's cool um but
i didn't that would be night too yeah i
didn't see anything yeah i i no ghosts i
didn't see any ghosts and i was very
open to it and i was like standing in
there at night sort of staring into the
mirror waiting for things to happen oh i
was embracing it i was like if
something's gonna happen i want to be
here for it but the ghosts left me alone
again beardingladyin.com that's not my
wreck but it is a wreck you should go
and check it out um next stop oklahoma
city
already in oklahoma
because you in the country i mean you
you drive for two days and you're in
oklahoma basically that's
see the country's not that big link
oklahoma city i i don't think i've ever
been there i have been to oakland
homeless well you have because you went
through on 40 with me well we went
through it but i don't think we stopped
we may have just stopped i think you've
been as a basketball player yeah i
remember the aau national championship
in 1996
was in oklahoma city and my team went to
play in the national championship did
you lose we didn't win
okay we played you forfeited what other
option is it well no and we played like
12th in the country it wasn't right
you weren't personally in the national
championship it was all the best aau
teams in the nation you were in the
tournament but not in almost top ten
we're pretty good you're really good
okay you're in the top ten the only
thing i remember is when you came back
was i think that's when you told me that
you were sleeping in bunk beds and that
your roommates
your teammates and roommates would bring
back
girls
to sleep in there or do something it
wasn't sleep it wasn't their bug beds it
was uh it was like a split level
condominium and so we were all sleeping
and like pulled out there was bedrooms
but there was also pull out couches and
me and a guy were sleeping in a pool on
a pullout bed together upstairs in the
loft but then there were two of our
other teammates who were downstairs in
another bed
and they live in the middle of the
living room and they were bringing girls
into
that bed and proceeding to make love to
them uh and there was lots of
open the first time i'd actually like
been in a room with someone else making
love there were four of them in one bed
no i think that one the one guy would be
like i'm gonna go do something else
while you bring your girl in here and
make love and then we'll switch okay
definitely i heard two different female
sounds
uh at different times yep yeah that's
you stated i wasn't really planning on
talking about this but thanks for
bringing it up that yes that is my
previous oklahoma city story okay top
that but of course what i'm interested
in the first thing i'm interested in is
i got what i came for uh first thing i'm
interested in is food and we actually
didn't quite get there at the right time
to for a meal but the place that i
wanted at your age yeah much more
interested in food than well there's two
things the the first thing was food and
talking about sex there was there's a
okay there's a restaurant that i think
is called 39
uh which is at the uh first nations
museum so there's this incredible native
american museum that's going up in
oklahoma of course there's a lot that
was a lot of the native american
territory and reservations and stuff
and covet has like severely dampened the
schedule for this thing but you can see
it as you're going by and 40 this
incredible structure that's going up but
it just wasn't open not open yet okay
but there's a restaurant that's gonna be
there that
it made it seem like it was open
uh it's called 39 because there's like
39 tribes that are local to that
to the state or to the region and there
was gonna be food from each one of those
tribes on the menu and i was like this
would be super cool but it wasn't clear
that it wasn't open yet i think it
opened sometime this year and the way i
figured out some of this is through
atlas obscura not all this was on
roadtrippers.com so i had the
roadtrippers.com up but then i would
like pull up oklahoma city on
uh atlas obscura
which is like a weird website that shows
interesting weird stuff stuff to
and uh weird things to do weird things
to see weird things that exist that you
can't have access to but also weird
things to eat like weird restaurants huh
you gotta pay for that no that's all
free oh that's free i like that but
there was this thing called the oklahoma
city underground which they made seem
cool
okay and this is essentially
un like okay i love underground stuff
i've established this i read a whole
book about it and i've always been
obsessed with like the under underneath
cities kind of thing and so i was
thinking that this was going to be
something like the parisian catacombs or
something you know like but it's
oklahoma city i should have
you know
changed my expectations yeah maybe it's
there's a subway and like a oh all it is
my hardware is the downtown oklahoma
city has been connected
via
pathways that are underneath
the ground let's call those tunnels
tunnels let's call them underground
walkways because you get too excited
about it they feel like hallways though
oh and they're and there's like it was
like oh it's home to art galleries and
stuff what they mean by that is that
there's a few places where all of a
sudden there'll be pictures on the wall
and they'll be like
purple lighting or red lighting or
yellow lighting like it's all lit but
then there's these signs that say like
progress energy building so and so
government building it's just like
buildings that i'm not interested in
going to and probably wouldn't have
access to
connected via underground you know what
it reminds me of
like the the suspended walkways in
minneapolis it's it's the same exactly
they were like it was like above ground
the skunk
so that you didn't have to be out in the
weather yeah it's similar to that maybe
it's because it seemed like a maze and
there wasn't it wasn't really a cool
place to be cause it's kind of cramped
it's exactly the same thing and i
actually think there are some skywalks
that are part of it once you get to some
of the buildings that are close together
all i can say is it's not very cool
um
okay i think we did take a dump in one
of the bathrooms there skipped that one
seemed super isolated and there was
nobody around he was picturing like
catacombs i'm sorry man well i wasn't
picturing catacombs i was picturing that
this was something that existed in the
past and had been commandeered for these
purposes versus something that was built
relatively recently is the way that it
feels it feels too sterile and just not
cool enough so we kind of walked
probably like half a mile and realized
it was all the same and walked back out
and that was it that was oklahoma city
for us oklahoma city proved to be a
disappointment my first trip back when i
listened to people have sex was
definitely a better trip so you didn't
top it but let's just move on on to
amarillo
and of course good morning when you're
going into amarillo this is the perfect
opportunity to introduce your son to the
music of george strait oh yeah famously
known for amarillo by morning and i
think more number one country hits of
any than any country artist that sounds
right to me
uh were you coming up from san antonio
no we were coming
from the east of oklahoma city was
everything that you got just what you
got i know we had a whole truck full of
things
yeah you didn't have a diamond car but
what you had was mine none of the song
applied to us in fact we weren't trying
to get there by morning we were trying
to get there to sleep what a good song
though did you play it oh we played that
and then proceeded to play
basically you just go to spotify and you
just play the most popular stuff from
george strait and you just remember like
oh yeah that one and that one and it's
not like my favorite country music of
all time but you immediately understand
why he had so many number one hits
because
first of all he had great songwriters
and he was a great great
deliverer
deliverer of baby blue i mean he was
just so good he was such a uh yeah we we
went through a bunch of them but uh yeah
christy got me the
george strait
cd box set when we were dating
and that i mean that was special there's
a lot of romance in there yeah his most
popular songs are
the love songs like even then he did the
whole string through the 90s like check
yes or no and all that stuff because it
gets a little cheesy yeah when i go back
and listen to it now and the 80s is my
sweet spot i wasn't able to
differentiate as a young and i wasn't
able to differentiate between how good
like amarillo by morning was compared to
check yes or no you know what i mean
like i'm sure that check yes or no
was preferred in the 90s but yeah i like
that little that old sound the chair
you play the chair for him oh yeah yeah
you didn't tell him ahead of time i i
had
the chair i had played i had played for
him before but not really as an
introduction to george strait and all
his music it was more just like hey this
is a this is a one of the classic
country songs was he into it he loved it
he loved it he he and he and then he
would do things like uh
take he would take a picture of of us
and put it on his instagram and then
amarillo morning would be like on a
story would be like the music that was
okay okay lot was having the time of his
life being introduced to some i mean he
knows pretty much all the music that
i've listened to but i was digging a
little bit deeper on this trip yeah and
it happened a little deeper that's
diamond rio that's a different uh well
hang on for diamond rio oh
so one of the things that lock wanted to
do i was like okay we're going to get to
amarillo and we're going to spend the
night
uh and then there's something we're
going to see in the morning in amarillo
but he was like okay we're coming into
texas like this is like friday night
lights dad we got to go we got to go to
an ice cream place oh that you wanted to
do like
sit down at an ice cream place like they
do on a friday night like that's right
okay so we go to this burger place tasty
freeze type yeah we go to this burger
place and well then that's when he's
like
uh first of all i don't can't remember
the name of the place but it's the
number one rated restaurant in amarillo
according to yelp and it's like a hole
hole-in-the-wall burger place that also
does rib eyes and mmm
it wasn't great
it just wasn't great i've had a lot of
really good burgers and it was and
people on yelp this is the best burger
i've ever had well i feel sorry for you
because there's much better burgers um
but then we saw this place pretty close
by called brahms i don't know if you've
ever this is a chain
in texas
that yeah kiko's b-r-a-h-m
b-r-a-u-m apostrophe s and it has like
an ice cream cone on it so i was like oh
an ice cream place it's open
we go in there it's not just an ice
cream place it is the it is a place that
serves like burgers and stuff like that
milkshakes but it also has ice cream so
it's got a bunch of places to sit and it
is a convenience store all open together
at this like a dairy themed convenience
store with like milk and yogurt and
stuff then gas station not a gas station
okay it is a restaurant i've never been
in a place like this in my life where
you've got the restaurant over here and
the convenience store over here and it's
all open there's no dividers and there's
like a cashier up there with a menu in
the ice cream sounds like a truck stop
to me it was unlike anything ever it was
not any of those things you're saying
and this is a chain yes it is a very
popular chain um and
shout out to the staff of the brahms and
amarillo many of whom are mythical
beasts
um
did they give you a chocolate uh well i
ordered my food i wasn't i don't know
i'm not looking
got to get those perks lock one of the
banana split again he was like in this
like friday night lights he's like i
could get it so he got a banana split
and first of all i was not hungry at all
but i got like a sunday and ate the
whole thing and of course you did that
was uh i i came to regret that the next
day
but then we just like at this point
we're staying in like we're using like
hotel tonight and like staying at
the holiday inn that's available you
know i'm last minute because i wasn't
exactly sure where we would make it so
we're not doing like that night was not
a destination hotel right
but we wake up in the morning and i
don't know if you remember this i mean
we stopped there before but right
outside of amarillo is the cadillac
ranch
which
again is basically a farmer who decided
that he was going to just plant
cadillacs i guess he was trying to grow
like been there but i've seen
potential so we didn't i've seen podo
it's weird that we didn't stop there
because we like
the
photos and it never heard it before how
do you how you said pohotos so we
stopped and got some potos at uh
the cadillac ranch it was so cold
that morning but literally all it is is
like a corn field or so the the crops
were not currently planted
and just cadillac's that and of course
no no entry peep fee no entry fee and
you can you can paint on them
there's a bunch of spray paint bottles
and people are constantly tagging them
to the point that like
there's the way that the paint is
dripping off of them it's created a
whole new entity of a painted cadillac
very cool great photo op or photo op we
did that uh but the next thing we were
trying to get to that day was
albuquerque
now to get to new mexico uh again i
always have like a food thing in mind
and then i've got like a sightseeing
thing in mind the food thing that i had
in mind was getting some of that new
mexican like green chili type food which
we stopped at a place i can't remember
the name of it but it was good we got
like the often at new mexico and new
mexican new mexican cuisine which is
different than just regular mexican food
you know there's an emphasis on
the green chili sauce but of course
albuquerque is known as the place where
breaking bad was filmed which is one of
my favorite shows of all time and one of
lock's favorite shows of all time we
didn't watch it concurrently because i
watched it a long time ago then he
watched it on his own like two years ago
so there are multiple fulfillment there
they filmed it they filmed any exterior
scene in breaking bad is in albuquerque
the car wash
walter white's house jesse's house yeah
i remember the house i knew i guess the
house was just like i didn't know if it
was a cheap lot they shot there a lot
again lots of outside shots places where
they got in fights on the road so i
think they either shot
they shot a lot of it in albuquerque
like a lot of it
not just exterior locations there's lots
of things going on there so were you
gonna do like a driving tour yeah so
there's multiple sites that have put
together the different stops and like
okay this part of town you can see these
things this part of town you can see
these things of course the thing that we
were most excited about was you know
walter and skyler's house the main the
main house yeah now i had kind of heard
that because none of this is official
and this is just somebody's private
residence that people who live there are
not exactly thrilled about this and in
fact in the thing that i looked up it
said the people who live here are not
happy about
the the fact that they own this historic
house and you know they kind of want you
to take your pictures from across the
street and get out of there so i was
like oh okay that's fine i'll just take
my picture from across the street and
get out of there just annoy the
neighbors by being in front of their
house yeah well i mean how annoying is
it for somebody to stop for a second
okay if it's a constant stream i get it
well
let me tell you
saying that they're not pleased with it
or they don't think it is ideal is the
understatement of the year oh okay
we pull up to the house
the first thing i noticed it's in a
neighborhood right it's in a
neighborhood it's in just like a suburb
there is a fence that has been erected
around the house okay that's completely
changes the look of it and changes the
view somewhat chain-link fence uh
i've got it there's a picture actually
i can't remember it's not it's not a
chain-link i don't think but you can
kind of see through it if i could but
it's change it doesn't look the same and
then there's multiple signs on the fence
and on the house that says
this is a private residence take your
pictures from across the street and move
on or something like that wow so we park
across the street and then we get out
and then i see that there is an older
lady who comes out
of the front door of the
house
and she just looks at me and this woman
looks
mad and she just stands there looking at
me like this crosses her arms sets up
and just makes eye contact with me and
just and i'm thinking like okay and i'm
like i gotta say something i'm like hey
how you doing you mind if we get a
picture
and she said i do mind this is a private
residence it has always been a private
residence and it will always be a
private residence what all these years
later she's the owner is having a
face-to-face interaction with you about
it and is this heated after all of this
time her i don't know when she bought
the house oh my god pre or post
but the thing is is it listen at that
point i felt so sorry for her and the
bit the level of bitterness that
is consuming her in her life yeah that i
was like okay no problem and instead of
like being an [ __ ] and like taking a
picture or talking back to her which i'm
sure a lot of people do i was just like
okay and we got back in the car and just
like
lot was like dad i told you that they
didn't like i was like you didn't tell
me that it was this serious of a thing
he was like no no micah my nephew and
his cousin micah said she really hates
it it was like you didn't tell me that
your nephews had visited it no they just
knew because lock said that we were
gonna do it and they like were talking
looked it up online
and i was just like man i just i
couldn't wrap my mind around like did
this woman buy this house and then let
them film there for a fee never
expecting that it would become this huge
cultural phenomenon and now she just
doesn't sell the house or did she buy
the house after the fact and didn't
fully know
how popular it was i mean all these
years later i mean i'm sure every year
that passes less and less people visit
sure but but as we were leaving there
was another person coming in you know oh
yeah it is a constant stream of traffic
so i can only imagine how the neighbors
feel i don't feel great about the fact
that we did it but you know i also don't
we weren't we were not intrusive and if
she hadn't said anything we would just
gotten out of the car in the middle of
the road taking a picture and just gone
on and no an annoyance yes
so i don't really know what the way if
you're gonna be annoyed by it i think
you have to sell the house to someone
who would think it was cool or like
vince gilligan should just buy the house
from this woman and you know
let people take all the pictures they
want i don't know i don't know what the
solution is yeah you've ruined this
person's life unintentionally well and
then they can't sell it at a price
because of what it is that they would
need to sell well that's the thing they
just left there trapped there lot was
like wouldn't the value go up i was like
no think about it whenever the the the
number of people who are interested in a
place goes down which less people
more people
would be turned off by the idea of
buying a landmark that people would come
to so if you lower the amount of people
who are demanding the house then the
price of the house goes down ironically
right so lance and lacy should buy it
and they turn it into a hotel yeah so i
don't know what their history is but i
felt bad about it like the rest of the
neighborhood probably won't let them
turn into an airbnb but that's what
should have happened that's does it
should be a freaking
yeah they put lansing on but that was
just the beginning of the the tour
because the next stop was the car wash
which i can't remember the name of the
car wash in the show but this is where
you know the car wash that walk buys the
lawn or the money yeah and it is still
intact and still functioning as a car
wash and it's just very iconic shape
so
we pull up to the car wash and there's a
giant open parking lot right next to it
which makes it easy to kind of stop and
just get a picture and like the guys
watching the cars kind of look at you
like yeah this happens all day every day
but it's a place of business yeah it's
not a big deal they don't care probably
there's a group of people who have just
taken pictures
in front of the car wash who are also on
the self-guided tour they're getting
back into their car and then lock and i
like take a picture and like take a
little video out there and then we see
them get back out of the car and there's
a girl who has this look on her face i'm
like this she must be a giant breaking
bad fan because she's coming back for
more
it turns out that she was a huge
mythical beast
and it was just you know it was crazy
don't go to walt's house she's i did i
said we just had an interaction with a
lady but uh because they had not been
there yet it was their next stop
i don't know if they went but yeah so
i can't remember your name you tweeted
at me after the fact and i can't i'm
sorry i can't remember your name but you
know who you are
uh we got some pictures out in front of
the car wash
um
and then we continued on to uh
give you a chocolate jesse pinkman's
house which okay apparently they're not
too keen on it but they weren't there
and there's no signs
and again as we stop deeper down to take
a picture another father and son in
another car for stopping right as we
left like it's a constant stream because
breaking bad is such an iconic show and
so many points of reference for it i
mean we've been to the the brady bunch
house in toluca lake well
there
there's all there's houses all over the
place like um
the uh
jamie lee
curtis's halloween house
britain took me there
and
they have they have a little sign says
take your picture but keep your distance
yeah
actually they had candy on their porch
and they were like
feel free to feel free to take some
candy take a picture and thank you for
being nice about this yeah to me it's
like
the main difference is like
if you live in new york city and you and
you like live in the city well there's
all kinds of stuff going on right
outside your front door constantly it's
a different lifestyle than what you
would get in suburban albuquerque yeah
but that would be my way of dealing with
it would be like hey listen people are
going to be constantly coming to our
house and taking pictures just make sure
they can't see in the windows and then
if they're if they come by we can greet
them stuff stuff man
but i i didn't i didn't sign up for it i
didn't let them film there and i didn't
buy the house okay
so that was albuquerque
the next stop was supposed to be we were
going to go keep going west and then go
up north to the grand canyon we were
actually going to go to monument valley
that very famous drive
in
in air i guess it's arizona
new mexico or arizona but it's it's like
you've seen it a million times one of
the most iconic drives in all of america
then there's a horseshoe
bend which is that crazy horseshoe
you've seen on instagram a thousand
times in the grand canyon but the winter
weather was really rolling in to the
tune of
it was going to be a high of like 18
degrees at the grand canyon and snowing
oh
and i'm in a expedition it's not a
four-wheel drive oh it's not okay
so i was like the idea of getting up
there and trying to drive through the
snow and also it being so cold i just
said we got to pull on audible we got to
go south we're going to miss the grand
canyon this is going to be a time
another time and place another time same
place that we will see the grand canyon
and all this other stuff
so i was scrambling at a uh that night
we were it was actually the night we
stayed in amarillo i was trying to
figure out like okay after we stopped in
albuquerque where we're going phoenix
well what i determined was is there were
two really cool things that i wanted to
see if we were to go south towards
tucson and yes and then into phoenix
okay um the first if you head south of
albuquerque you you can if you're
heading towards tucson you can kind of
divert off and kind of go through some
crazy wilderness and see something
called the very large array
now i don't know if you remember but
like when we made the seti song and we
had like stock pictures of these
satellites that are just all giant
satellites like pointing towards the sky
that's the very large array it's the
largest array of radio telescopes i
think in definitely north america maybe
the world
it's 20
i said it's 22 miles across and locked
thought i meant one satellite that was
22 miles across so he was
a little bit disappointed when we showed
up there
it's just 22 miles
across a field essentially of these
giant like once you get right up next to
them these giant telescopes that are
making all these incredible discoveries
you can drive through them
well covid had closed down the visitor
center which also includes a self-guided
tour where you can like walk directly up
to one without trespassing
uh we did walk pretty much up to one
with a very minor trespassing
um because it's just this middle of this
field literally there's cows all around
them i mean it's like cattle grazing out
there the
that drive out there is so incredible
that part of the country is just
beautiful and desolate and
i mean you go you drive and drive and
drive and drive and you finally oh
there's giant satellites on these like
basically
railroad tracks is how they kind of like
move them around or like do maintenance
on them because there's a railroad track
it's all operable they're still
listening for aliens okay so
it i thought that
the whole purpose of the thing was
listening for aliens but no it's a
government program where
um
well it might be private i
the government is involved nasa's
involved
because they're uh using radio telus
telescopes to
discover black holes and all this
information about the galaxy so they're
constantly scanning the skies using
radio frequencies to essentially
that's how radio telescopes work mapping
and getting pictures of things using
radio frequencies and they're incredibly
sensitive and there's a bunch of them
but seti uh the search for
extraterrestrial whatever it's that that
thing that people who are listening for
extraterrestrial life out in the cosmos
yeah they've partnered with them okay
and so they basically have access to the
stream of data that all these satellites
are gathering
but it's pretty crazy i wish we could
have gone in
to the gift shop and gotten some
souvenirs but we just got some cool
pictures
that's pretty much all we got
but the goal was to get to a place
called globe arizona which is in the
mountains basically
arizona has a
quite a landscape i don't know i never
heard a globe
you would there's no reason to it was
just a spot that kind of made sense for
us to get to to then be able to go to
our next stop the next day but the
problem with this is even though i had i
was so thankful that we had gone south
but going through the mountains the
elevation got up to like five or six
thousand feet and we went through like
blizzard-like conditions really multiple
times at night trying to get the globe
and i was like we we stopped in eight
uh in this middle of nowhere town and
then i'm like looking at the elevation
of where we're at in the elevation of
where we need to get and it's down so
i'm like okay well it's not going to get
any worse than it is right now i didn't
know that it was going to require me
going up higher and then
so there was like multiple times where i
kind of got to
snow just like blinding snow down the
side of a mountain
and i'm like freak i'm freaking out
right and and lock's like dad just relax
i'm like i don't want to get stuck are
there other cars driving in this very
few this is that just kept scaring me
too there's just very few other people
who have made a decision to be on the
road and so i'm going pretty slow it
took us a while
we finally get low enough where we're we
start seeing some cactus and we're
outside of the uh it's all dark and i
can kind of see him with my headlights
but we stop and spend the night in globe
again just like we're just going with
whatever's open at that point just some
hotel you're just ramblers at this point
it's all blurring together but we and we
were headed for
biosphere
2. now i got the t-shirt to prove it
biosphere 2.
i've watched a documentary
all about biosphere 2. and we talked
about it pretty extensively on gmm a
couple years ago as well oh i didn't
okay because i watched this much more
recently it's been years since we talked
about it on gmm because it started in
this
in the 70s maybe earlier no it's in the
90s it was the 90s was the eight well no
it was the maybe the late 80s early 90s
definitely they were wearing like 80s
clothes
i thought it was okay maybe
well definitely 80s it was definitely
the 80s it wasn't earlier than that i
mean they started research earlier than
that i mean but
i i remember this from when i was a kid
it's a private funded
biosphere self-contained
human experiment
of well
an an experiment of sending these humans
into this
a team it's kind of like astronauts but
they're going into this biosphere and
completely self-contained so in
certifying then nothing's going to go in
or out including the air just so so this
was basically an experiment to see if
human life can be sustained in one of
these things and the applications could
be
on another planet or at the end of the
world that kind of thing so
the atmosphere was completely
self-contained the water that they used
completely self-contained
uh every all they grew their own food
nothing for two years nothing could come
in or out except for the breaches yeah
that then the press jumped all over
which is part of the the documentary's
pretty decent i watched it on a plane
here the thing that i was so knowing a
little bit right
knowing a little bit about the history i
was like
who owns it okay oh the university of
arizona owns it now i'm like i wonder if
they've like completely covered their it
says they're using it actively for
research now so i was just like is this
gonna be a place that like is
embarrassed by the history of biosphere
because it was kind of a big
embarrassment a lot of ways and a
failure in a lot of ways
are they gonna be embarrassed by it and
like are they still like associated with
the same people and so they're like
glossing over and trying to make it seem
like it was better than it was no they
fully embraced exactly what happened
and they've left a lot of it intact
including like this is an apartment
where one of the people lived and you
can look inside and see this is the
kitchen that's exactly how it was so you
took a tour inside yes i went in every
part of it oh how long does that take
it took us about an hour and a half and
we were going
we were moving pretty fast okay that's
pretty cool so there's like a rain
forest you would be you could but you
could go outside and you could spectate
like you did the breaking bad house and
like look through the glass because it
was glad the scientists working and
stuff but of course you couldn't go
inside because there were
no breeches but this was one of the
highlights of the trip cool because it's
huge right so it looks huge it's uh like
a huge greenhouse inside is four acres
which if you can imagine a house that's
four acres that's a giant house
you know people don't really it's
smaller than i thought though well but
if you
but like think about most lots if you
have an acre
of land in los angeles that's like
10 times bigger than everybody else's
house oh sure and then if the whole
thing is covered with a house and you do
that times four
it's a lot of it's it's massive once you
get inside
and it's all still working and all still
functional uh like there's a like they
have an indoor ocean which at the time
they had gone and collected coral and
stuff and created an active
coral reef in there
the coral reef has died because
at some point another columbia
university owned it before university of
arizona and they kind of let the coral
reef die for whatever reason but it's
still they're actively studying some
things and they're actually going to try
to make it a coral reef again
um there's a cut there's a number of
like scientific
elements of like the way that the
the energy was self-contained and there
was these giant if you see the picture
of biosphere there's these giant domes
you can't go inside those but those are
basically
giant diaphragms they're called lungs
to allow when the pressure
air pressure increases because of
temperature changes
it expands and like it's like a bubble
that fills up to allow the pressure of
the air to not
bust the windows out oh wow because it's
unusual to have something that's so
self-contained
you got to have some way to like let the
pressure
come and go and i i i do remember from
the documentary that like
the
inhabitants started getting really sick
because the oxygen levels were so low
the oxygen that's the first thing where
they had to they had to get some outside
help yeah the oxygen level ended up
going from like 21 to like 14
which makes you a little bit crazy and
it's also dangerous
yeah so it didn't quite work out but
i highly recommend this is right outside
of tucson highly recommended stop if you
find yourself in that
area and they have a cool t-shirt i
would like to do that um now
we're coming this trip is about to come
to a close like again this is only the
this is the the 30th
and like the thought was okay now the
time to like do the retrospective
montage uh
no you've seen you've seen quite a bit
okay by this point but we got to go
through phoenix and the idea was okay
let's just stop in phoenix and then
hang out in phoenix and see what we can
get into and then we'll stay in phoenix
but that was also when we looked and saw
that you don't phoenix is only five and
a half hours from melee the classic
should we just get home conversation it
wasn't we weren't going to stop in
phoenix it was like do we need to stay
in phoenix let's just get home late and
just sleep in our own beds so we kind of
determined to do that
uh but there's a couple of things about
phoenix i don't think i've ever actually
been defeated i've been around it they
got a big belt line maybe we stopped
there for a tour or something i just i
don't remember everywhere we've been but
like fifth largest city in america did
you know that could not have told you
that behind like la new york chicago and
i guess boston you tell my square
footage
people people yes it's and it's also
because it includes like scottsdale and
some other places that you like heard of
as a city but it's also really just
physically largest it's giant um
the thing i notice about phoenix is
nothing against any of the other places
that i visited
but phoenix is the first place where i
was like
just began to recognize
um
like you're searching for the diplomatic
way to say this what is it i'll just say
hipsters okay
you know i was going to say cool people
but i started to feel there was a pr
approximate hipster contingent no
heretofore not experienced after
nashville nashville has a hipster
component but when you go to the
downtown area in nashville you're in the
it's like going to hollywood california
you know it's it's like hollywood
boulevard it's this is
no one's from no one's from there except
maybe you found that in phoenix
yeah some too good for their own good
coffee shops yeah we were talking coffee
shops breweries we ate at this place
called i think it was the wilderness
brewery and there was like a bunch of
hipsters there and okay i felt very at
home so you wanna you might be eyeing
phoenix huh well
the thing is so we were it's roosevelt
row which is kind of like their arts
district and it was really it was really
cool
um and then i started
i was like oh phoenix is like a cool
place that like we could come on for
like a weekend because it's like it's
the same distance just driving to san
francisco it's not that bad
but then i start looking at the glo the
average daily temperature throughout the
year and there's like
six or seven months where it's like
above a hundred hertz
it's a hot place you know so i don't
know how they deal with that exactly
besides just going inside but
it seems like there's some good times to
visit dry heat though there's some
there's some good times to visit
phoenix
but one of the things i skipped over in
terms of music is
somewhere in this part of the trip
is when i'm beginning to think like
um
i gotta well i gotta introduce lot to
some other stuff and that was when i was
like oh you know what i think he'll like
diamond rio oh
after george strait yeah
and uh because i was like speaking in
90s country i was like there was these
guys that link and i were really really
into
and they were
you know they they kind of
i'm not going to call them a flash in
the pan they're still together and
they're still making music but the 90s
they peaked pretty hard they had 90.
three really solid albums i don't know
and almo well i would say i would say
four
had some really and they had a good hit
i don't know if they were number ones
they probably were because they had some
incredible songs right bluegrass infused
90s country
lots of harm the vocal the vocal
approach is the thing that is so
uh notable about them and i would say
that yes to the bluegrass niche of it
all but it doesn't have that
it doesn't get into bluegrass sort of
chord structure
and tempo
it's like kind of country
rocky
with this infused the singing and i
could just look on lock's face as we
were like listening to love a little
stronger and then one more day which
didn't you have one more day played at
your wedding
one more day no that's that's talking
about if somebody's dead died right
no it's uh i know how the river feels oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
but one more day when you meet your your
soul mate
and they're still living okay
well we'll play one more day at your
funeral one more day sad is a great song
and
so like there's so many great songs so
from that point in the trip so this is
like the last two days he just kept
wanting to go back to
those four or five really amazing
diamond rio songs and then he's like
he's like texting me
recently i was like dad we got to go to
a diamond rio concert
so he's all in on diamond rio they're
great yeah
definitely
top five country
artists i i think i might have to put
them in my top five of artists not just
i mean definitely groups
um and definitely 90s
but this is okay so we're we're on day
five
and we have driven quite a bit but we're
also kind of saying let's sleep in our
own beds and we just go ahead and we
make the trip through we we get back to
la at like 10 30 at night and let me
just say that
lock and i are very similar in a lot of
ways
um
we
which is a is a recipe for fights
right
and
we did not get into and of course he's
17. like we're when we're at home in our
normal everyday lives where there's
things there's things like you didn't
take the trash out there's these and
lots of little things that could then
turn into an argument
but we got through this trip without any
sort of friction we were having an
incredible time together listening to
music seeing this stuff we talk about
pretty much everything
philosophy
everything that we
and where we lit we were listening to
one of my favorite uh
books
uh siddhartha
which i listened to on my uh my solo
trip and it was something that he had
been wanting to listen to which is a
short audiobook it's really easy to
listen to so we're having this
incredible time
and then like 20 minutes from home is
when we like got into our first like
argument
and it was like it escalated really
quickly i don't even know what it was
about and then i was like listen
this can't we can't like there's no
reason for us to fight right now
let's just get home let's get home and
just forget about this and we did
um no but i'm so first of all multiple
times throughout the trip he was like
i'm so glad i did this i was wrong i'm
glad you talked me into this like
telling everybody about it and how good
of a time he had
um it is the kind of thing that
he's going to remember forever i'm not
and i think it actually might is more
likely to now lead to us doing another
trip together maybe for a spring break
don't know exactly what we're going to
do
but it was a success a father-son
success um
and so there wasn't a point like okay
well what did you learn son no what are
you going to remember forever well one
of the things that i've come to grips
with is
every dad has a most dads
i think have a tendency to datify things
and to try to
find the lesson or the moral in
something
and like my kids have to codify
something to feel there is an impulse to
like
let's actually let's land this plane and
i i am doing a good job as a dad right
it's it's a question well but you seek
to answer the thing that drives that
well the thing that has come very clear
to me is that that is for me only that's
not for a lot yeah right that exercise
is one hundred percent for my own ego
and so it and own sense of security
and i'm using ego broadly
so and i actually made i actually made
the decision there's no lecturing
there's no
trying to get him to see something a
certain way on this trip now
what i found is that he actually is very
interested in what i think about things
he's very interested in my opinion and
when i don't
use every conversation as a jumping off
point for some lesson or giving him some
perspective he just naturally asks me or
runs things by me in a way that is very
clear that what he's after is what i
think about this now i have to be really
careful once i start talking about those
things to not turn it into a lecture
and to make it more well i mean one way
to see that is this or here's one thing
that i would think about
but it was you know we had like we
really had some
really great conversations about a lot
of things that
we kind of talk about from time to time
but in in the the setting of this well
there's no place to go we got to kill
time
it really
um it lent itself to those kind of
conversations and he was very much
all for it it was i mean it was great
for for our relationship and you know
and now that we're back in the swing of
just regular life yes there's been
there's been some arguments again
um but i think that there's there's a
connection that was really that was
already there of course but it was just
strengthened and enhanced through this
so highly recommend it if you have the
opportunity to take a trip
that's that's my trip son i i my wreck
is one other
is the
album that we listen to
more than any album that we both just
fell in love with
uh i think i have told you about this
guy but i don't know how much you've
listened to him brent cobb yeah he's got
a song that's really popular like
keep them on their toes or something
like that yeah and like any artist there
are some albums or some songs that don't
really resonate but he's got an album
from a few years back called shine on a
rainy day
and this is the this is the one that we
just centered in on
and i i like his most recent album as
well but he's a he's a south georgia boy
he's born very close to where i was born
he's got a song about
i think called south of atlanta which is
about going back to his hometown and i
think he now lives he was in nashville
for a while but now he lives down there
in south georgia is it laid back this
album yeah that's the thing is that he's
you know he's gotta he'll go a little
bit rock in some places where which is
why i don't like as much on this album
it's almost exclusively just like
thoughtful
sort of soulful
good country and again this isn't the
kind of country you're going to hear
on country radio this is way better than
that yeah yeah um and it's just so
amazing to me that they don't play this
music on the radio but
brent cobb
georgia boy
huge fan shine on a rainy day
just starts off with a song about uh
sitting on a porch and solving the
problems of the world and it just goes
on from there
um so that's my wreck wow great road to
trip music but also just great music
in general i'm glad he had i'm glad you
made it
yeah
relationship didn't fall not only intact
but uh you know you got some memories
that will last his lifetime of course
you know you're going to pass on at some
point and then he'll live on
a little bit of that'll live on in his
memory
that's true and in video form for those
of you who watch the video
there's there's there's a lot there's a
lot to see that link didn't even get to
see you're going to have to watch this
one
all right we'll talk at you next week
hashtag here biscuits weigh in
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]